Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在我们深入今天的节目之前，我想快速告知大家一件现在正在进行、令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造为你带来收益的收入，而不是不断用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“冲刺持续性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, we are looking at the field of occupational psychology.
这些原则都对你适用。本次挑战赛还有由丽莎本人直接颁发的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战赛，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一辅导一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个快速私信，我会把所有详细信息发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。在接下来的节目中，我们将探讨职业心理学领域。
I am joined by a guest who is just coming to the very end of the process in qualifying in this fascinating career that bridges the gap between the workplace and human behavior. Whether you are listening because you are looking for a career change or maybe looking to dive in at an earlier stage of your career, then you are in the right place. We look at the key aspects of this career, how to get started, how to get qualified and so much more. Hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. One of the joys of creating this podcast is that I'm able to illuminate different facets of professional psychology careers. And I wanted to revisit in more detail something that we spoke about
我邀请到了一位嘉宾，她刚刚完成了在这个迷人职业中获得资格认证的最后流程。这个职业架起了工作场所与人类行为之间的桥梁。无论你是因为寻求职业转型而收听，还是希望在职业生涯的早期阶段就深入了解，你都来对地方了。我们将探讨这个职业的关键方面、如何开始、如何获得资格认证等等。希望你会觉得非常有用。嗨，欢迎收听“有抱负的心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。制作这个播客的乐趣之一，就是能够阐明专业心理学职业的不同侧面。我想更详细地重新探讨一些我们曾讨论过的话题，
with Dr. Mari Kovinen when we were looking at a variety of issues, including growing up in Finland and looking at dating in psychology and occupational psychology. But I wanted to dedicate a whole episode to occupational psychology, which is what we are doing today. It's going to be really useful for you whatever stage of career you are at and whether you are interested in occupational psychology or not I think there's something to be gained by listening to it or watching it. That said if you are watching on YouTube please do subscribe, like, share the content, drop me a comment below. In the episode we do talk about whether there is funding available for student finance and my guest wasn't quite sure
当时我们和马里·科维宁博士（Dr. Mari Kovinen）探讨了各种问题，包括在芬兰长大、探讨心理学中的约会以及职业心理学。但我希望用一整期节目来专门探讨职业心理学，这就是我们今天要做的。无论你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，无论你对职业心理学是否感兴趣，这期节目对你都将非常有用，我认为收听或观看它都会让你有所收获。话虽如此，如果你正在 YouTube 上观看，请务必订阅、点赞、分享内容，并在下方给我留言。在节目中，我们确实讨论了学生贷款是否有资金支持，我的嘉宾当时不太确定
of the answer. I've had a little bit of a google and it looks like the best thing to do is to contact the student finance department in the country that you are living in. So I'm in England, for me it would be Student Finance England because it seems to be done on a case by case basis, depending on what stage of career you are at, and whether you've had previous funding. I would love to know what you think of this episode. I hope you find it so useful. I will catch up with you on the other side. I just want to welcome along our guests for today. Hi, Jo. Hi, Marianne. Thanks for inviting me. Oh thank you so much for saying yes. So we got chatting on LinkedIn and I was like would you fancy coming on and doing a podcast episode and thankfully you said yes. I did and that's one of my, I like saying yes to lots of things, that's
这个答案。我刚刚稍微谷歌了一下，看起来最好的做法是联系你所居住国家的学生财务部门。所以我在英国，对我来说就是英国学生财务处（Student Finance England），因为这似乎是按个案处理的，取决于你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，以及你以前是否获得过资助。我很想知道你对这期节目的看法。希望你觉得它非常有用。我们在节目的另一端见。我只想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾。嗨，乔（Jo）。嗨，玛丽安。谢谢你邀请我。哦，非常感谢你答应。我们在领英（LinkedIn）上聊过，然后我说你愿意来做一期播客节目吗，谢天谢地你答应了。我确实答应了，这是我的其中一个，我喜欢对很多事情说“好”，这是
one of my potential pitfalls but yes I was really excited about this so thank you oh thank you for squeezing me in at a time when actually you're quite busy anyway because you've just been telling me that you're kind of coming to the end stages of getting everything sorted so that you can call yourself an occupational psychologist which is very exciting yeah yes so in fact I've just spent this morning finishing off my amends to send my thesis, submit my thesis for to the examiners so I can get that rubber stamped. And then that kind of closes that journey, which has been an amazing journey. I'm really obviously looking forward to sharing some of it with you today. Oh, congratulations in advance. And tell us a little bit about how did you come to doing this particular field in
我潜在的缺点之一，但我真的对这个感到很兴奋，所以谢谢你。哦，谢谢你在你本来就很忙的时候抽时间接待我，因为你刚刚告诉我，你正处于完成所有事情的最后阶段，这样你就可以称自己为职业心理学家了，这非常令人兴奋。是的，事实上，我今天上午刚完成修改，把论文发出去，将我的论文提交给考官，这样我就可以得到盖章批准了。然后这就结束了那段旅程，这是一段奇妙的旅程。我当然非常期待今天能与你分享其中的一部分。哦，提前恭喜你。能跟我们讲讲你是怎么开始从事心理学这个特定领域的吗？
psychology? Yeah I mean I know everyone's got an interesting story so I'm a little bit biased in saying that mine's super interesting but I guess it's interesting in that there was quite a significant career transition so I spent the first almost 20 years of my career in sales and marketing and a very traditional career in terms of, you know, looking for promotions. It was that traditional kind of vertical linear type career in sales and marketing and got to a point where I was marketing director and sales responsibility across Europe, big team, everything I'd always wanted. But something, you know, it wasn't evidently, it wasn't really. So I got there and then went, oh, actually, this isn't really what I want to do anymore. Also, at the time, from a contextual perspective, I had a small child. I was trying to be this great mom, trying to be this great boss, trying to be superwoman in all domains. And, you know, that then kind of started having some consequences for my well-being.
是的，我的意思是，我知道每个人都有一个有趣的故事，所以我说我的故事超级有趣可能有点偏见，但我想它有趣的地方在于，这是一次相当重大的职业转型。我职业生涯的前将近 20 年都奉献给了销售和营销，就寻找晋升机会而言，这是一份非常传统的职业。这是销售和营销领域中那种传统的垂直线性职业，直到我达到了营销总监的位置，负责欧洲的销售责任，拥有庞大的团队，拥有一切我一直想要的东西。但有些东西，你知道，显然，并不是那么回事。所以我到达了那个位置然后说：“哦，实际上，这并不是我真正想做的事情。”此外，当时从背景的角度来看，我有一个小孩子。我试图成为一个好妈妈，试图成为一个好老板，试图在所有领域都成为女超人。你知道，这开始对我的健康产生一些影响。
And I recognized that and decided to take charge and do something different. So I exited my corporate career I said after almost 20 years and started off my own consultancy and actually at that in those first couple of years it was a marketing consultancy I just took you know this is what I do this is what I'm good at and and brought it into consulting um then I started finding a lot of the work I was doing was using some of my kind of leadership skills that I'd kind of developed over my corporate career doing leadership work doing management change projects helping organizations going through change and I started kind of realizing
我意识到了这一点，并决定掌控局面，做一些不同的事情。所以我退出了我的企业职业生涯，就像我说的，将近 20 年后退出了，并开始了我自己的咨询工作。实际上，在那头两年里，它是一家营销咨询公司，我只是拿着，你知道，这就是我所做的，这就是我擅长的，然后把它带入了咨询中。然后我开始发现我所做的大部分工作都在运用我在企业生涯中培养的一些领导力技能，做领导力工作，做管理变革项目，帮助经历变革的组织。我开始意识到
this is this is quite different but this is what really like. And that's when I started exploring opportunities to actually, you know, build my credentials through education. So that's when I started looking at courses that would enable me to be better at that, be more informed, use evidence-based practice as opposed to just going out on the whim. And that's when I came across the the master's in occupational psychology at Birkbeck. Amazing so you decided to take the plunge? I took the plunge went back to studying after 22 years my my undergraduate degree was in social science I majored in economics and sociology so I don't have a psychology degree.
这很不寻常，但这正是我真正喜欢的。也就是在那时，我开始探索通过教育来真正建立我的资历的机会。因此，我开始寻找能够让我在这方面做得更好、更有见识、使用循证实践而不是仅仅凭一时冲动行事的课程。也就是在那时，我遇到了伯克贝克学院（Birkbeck）的职业心理学硕士学位。太棒了，所以你决定冒险一试？我冒险一试，在时隔 22 年后重新开始学习。我的本科专业是社会科学，主修经济学和社会学，所以我没有心理学学位。
Well, I kind of do now. But so I didn't know that was more of a social science. So I enrolled on the organizational psychology master's program at Birkbeck. I did it full time in a year because I'm so desperate to learn it all really quickly. In hindsight, that might not have been the best best idea but um that's that's the route I took um and then I got to near the end and I was just in a bit of a I love this journey I love this I love it I I just find this so fascinating I don't want it to stop um and obviously because I'd chosen full-time it was it was coming to an end and I wasn't really ready for it to end and so I recall talking to our professor of our department at the time saying how do I carry on this and it was just
好吧，我现在算是有了一个。但我当时并不知道，那更偏向社会科学。所以我注册了伯克贝克学院的组织心理学硕士课程。我用一年时间全职读完了它，因为我太渴望非常快地把所有东西都学完了。事后看来，这可能不是最好的主意，但那就是我选择的道路。然后我读到了快结束的时候，我正处于一种“我热爱这段旅程，我热爱这个，我太喜欢它了，我只是觉得太迷人了，我不想让它停下来”的状态。而且显然因为我选择了全职，它就要结束了，而我还没准备好让它结束。所以我记得当时和我们部门的教授谈过，问我如何继续这个项目。当时正好
very fortuitous at the time Birkbeck were bringing the professional doctorate in occupational psychology to fruition and I was advised that might be a nice route, you know, because I kind of wanted to work in practice as a practitioner, independent practitioner. So I applied for that and managed to actually coerce one of my friends who was also on the MSc to do it so we could do it together and we both got accepted so we handed in our master's dissertations and a week later we were enrolled on the professional doctorate that was back in 2019. Gosh that's amazing like amazing excellent timing but you're clearly the right candidates for those roles as well. Tell us a little bit about the professional doctorate so is it how big are the cohorts do you get paid to train you know do you have to pay tuition fees yes so you do have to pay um and it's something in the region of about five ish thousand pound
非常机缘巧合，伯克贝克学院正在将职业心理学专业博士学位（Professional Doctorate）付诸实现，我被告知这可能是一个不错的途径，你知道，因为我希望能作为一名实践者、独立实践者在实践中工作。所以我申请了那个项目，并且设法说服了我的一个也读过硕士的朋友和我一起读，这样我们就可以一起做了。我们俩都被录取了，于是我们交了硕士毕业论文，一周后我们就注册了专业博士学位，那是 2019 年。天哪，太棒了，时间把握得太棒了，但你显然也是这些角色的合适人选。给我们讲讲专业博士学位吧，它的学员规模有多大？你培训有薪水吗？你知道，你必须支付学费吗？
a year so there is there's obviously a cost there um you are working while you're doing it because actually the part one so if you are um if you don't um if you don't already have the bps chartership if you're going in it from scratch as i was the part one is you are working and you are then doing reflective learning logs based on the piece of work and obviously if you're fortunate enough you will be getting paid for that work um because i'm an independent practitioner i was i did a little mixture some projects i was getting paid for other projects i had to do pro bono simply because i had to write i had to do the piece of work and it was during covid so you had to kind of make some
是的，你必须付费，大约在每年五千英镑左右，所以显然有这笔费用。你是一边工作一边完成它的，因为实际上第一部分是——如果你还没有英国心理学会（BPS）的特许资格，如果你像我一样从头开始——第一部分是你正在工作，然后你根据所做的工作写反思学习日志。显然，如果你足够幸运，你会为那项工作获得报酬，因为我是一名独立实践者，我做了一个小小的混合，有些项目我有报酬，其他项目我必须做免费（pro bono）服务，仅仅因为我必须写，我必须完成那项工作。而且那是在新冠疫情期间，所以你必须做出一些
decisions um around okay i'll have to do some stuff and not get paid for it in order to get the qualification. So there was a little bit of a mix. You kind of cover you cover the five main areas. So selection and assessment, engagement and motivation, leadership, change and then learning and development. Those were the those were the five topic areas and so you do a meaty piece of work within that domain and then you write up a sort of 5 000 word reflective log on the using the consultancy cycle as the kind of framework evidence-based practice to demonstrate um you know that you have delivered work to the standard of of um you know doctoral student amazing thank you so there's those five key areas but the one thing that i felt like i
决定，围绕着“好吧，为了获得资格，我得做一些没有报酬的事情”。所以有一点混合。你涵盖了五个主要领域。即选拔与评估、投入与动机、领导力、变革以及学习与发展。这些就是这五个主题领域，你在该领域内做了一项实质性的工作，然后使用咨询周期（consultancy cycle）作为框架的证据基础，写了一份大约 5000 字的反思日志，以证明你已经完成了达到博士生标准的各项工作。太棒了，谢谢。所以有这五个关键领域，但我感觉我了解的关于职业心理学的唯一一件事却不在其中。哦，真的吗？是的，或者可能我只是没有把它归纳进去。我想我接受过的唯一相关教学是在我们做一个模块时，或者研究病态建筑综合症（sick building syndrome），也就是当整个员工队伍因为建筑物的搭建方式而生病的时候，你知道，它没有让人感到舒适，没有符合人体工程学，也没有为人类机能提供自主性。所以我想这在某种程度上是职业心理学的一部分，但等等，我知道，事实上其实有第六个领域，那就是福祉（well-being）。所以存在一个福祉领域，我的一些同行将他们的重点放在福祉倡议上，所以那是我的错。
knew about occupational psychology wasn't there so oh really yeah or maybe i'm just not fitting it in so i think the only teaching i've ever had on it was when we were doing a module or looking at sick building syndrome, which is like when a whole workforce became ill because of the way the, you know, the building was kind of set up and it just wasn't making people feel good and wasn't kind of ergonomic or wasn't autonomous for human functioning. So I kind of thought that was kind of partly the role of occupational psychology but yeah I know well in fact I'm there is actually a sixth area which is well-being so um there is a well-being area so some some um of my peers did their focus on well-being initiatives so that that's that's my mistake
我应该，我应该说过，你曾说过福祉是一个，事实上我读硕士时就是做这个的，所以我应该知道的。没关系。所以你有一个最喜欢的领域吗？你有一个在职业心理学中想做的梦想项目吗？我的兴趣领域是工作中的动机，我的博士研究和论文是关于工作中的主动行为（proactive behavior），也就是围绕自我发起、以变革为导向、面向未来的、关于挑战现状的行为。所以那是那种能够推动变革的行为。而且我认同自己具有主动型人格，所以这是一个我特别感兴趣的领域，就像很多博士生做的那种他们能够与之产生共鸣并希望更多地了解自己的事情一样，这有点像是一段探索之旅，那是让我觉得非常迷人的领域。我现在在伯克贝克学院教授“雇员关系与动机”模块，所以我现在在硕士课程上教书。所以这算是一个完整的循环，我是一名获得认证的教练（coach），我特别喜欢做这样的工作：指导那些感到有些卡住的客户。他们正在拖延，看不到前进的方向。当有人带着这样的教练困境来找我时，我就觉得：“太好了，这就是这个。”我喜欢做所有与动机相关的事情。我觉得非常有动力。所以这是我超级感兴趣的事情，
I should have I should have said that you said well-being is a that that's that's my mistake I should have I should have said that you said well-being is a is quite a um in fact I did my master's on that so I should have I should have known that no worries at all um so do you have like a favorite area do you have like a a dream piece of work that you like to do in occupational psychology so my area of interest is motivation at work and my doctoral research my thesis was in proactive behavior at work which is around self-initiated change oriented future focus about challenging the status quo so it's that kind of behavior that um drives change and that's um I identify as having a proactive personality so it was an area I was particularly interested in as a lot of doctoral students do this thing that they kind of
但我对领导力也非常感兴趣，体验过一些伟大的领导力，体验过一些不太好的领导力，并且自己担任过领导角色，想要成为一个真正优秀的领导者，这也是让我着迷的事情，它在某种程度上与动机息息相关。是的，我想没有什么比在商业中工作并看到事情做得很好，或者看到事情做得真的很糟更能激励你成为带来改变的那种改变了。是的，绝对的。绝对的。所以现在你几乎已经具备了资格，因为 99% 只是在等待盖章批准。你打算只以个体经营的身份工作，寻找合同吗？
can relate to and want to understand a bit more about themselves it's a bit of a sort of journey of discovery um and that's my area that I um found really fascinating I teach um on the um employee relations and motivation module at Birkbeck now so I teach on the master's program now um so it's kind of gone full circle and I I'm an accredited coach so I particularly like doing work where I'm coaching clients who feel a bit stuck. They're procrastinating, can't see a way forward. That's kind of my when someone comes to me with that as a coaching dilemma, I'm like, yes, this is what this is. I love doing so all things related to motivation. I find very motivating. And so that's my sort of thing I'm super interested in
人们有时会雇佣职业心理学家担任受雇职位吗？这是怎么运作的？是的，所以我将分享我个人的经历，但我的经历与其他人的很不一样。所以我如前所述是一名独立实践者，我有自己的咨询业务，并且有所谓的组合职业（portfolio career）。在其中，我有一些独立的咨询工作，做一些指导（coaching），做领导力发展，我接一些不错的战略项目，做过一些围绕变革、投入、文化的事情。所以它们往往是定制的，是一个短期的项目，也可以更长，所以这就是我的咨询工作。指导方面，正如我所说，我直接与客户合作，指导客户。
but I'm also really interested in leadership and you know the impact of leaders having experienced some great leadership having experienced some not so great leadership and having been in a leadership role and wanting to be a really good leader so that's also something that I've I'm fascinated by and it links with motivation to a certain degree yeah I guess nothing like working in business and seeing things done well or seeing things done really badly to inspire you to be the difference that makes the difference. Yes, absolutely. Absolutely. And so now you are pretty much almost qualified, because 99% kind of just waiting for the rubber stamping. Are you going to be working just in a self-employed capacity, kind of looking for contracts?
我也做了相当多的向领导者传授指导基础知识的工作，使组织能够开展那种“领导者即教练”类型的计划。所以我做了很多非常简化的指导工作。然后我有几份工作是更偏向带薪角色的。比如我是南方合作社（Southern Co-op）的非执行董事。那是一家地区性合作社。我进入了那个董事会。但我也担任董事会的多元化与包容性（D&I）大使，我主持薪酬委员会。
Do people sometimes employ occupational psychologists in an employed capacity? How does it work yeah so I'll share kind of my personal experience and then but mine is quite different to others so um so I am as said independent practitioner so I've got my own consultancy and I have what's called a portfolio career so within that I have my independent consultancy work so I do some coaching I do leadership development I pick up nice little strategic projects I've done sort of stuff around change engagement culture stuff so they're they're kind of tend to be kind of bespoke it's you know it's a short project or it can be longer so that's's my kind of consultancy stuff. Coaching, as I said, I work directly with clients, coaching clients.
因此，我所做工作的一些优势与此重叠。正如我所提到的，我在伯克贝克学院的硕士课程上教书。哦，一点变化绝对是生活的调味剂，不是吗？是的，是的，确实如此。所以，你提到你真的很喜欢变革，对于我们的许多听众或观众来说，他们可能会想到变革阶段模型（stages of change model），那是普罗查斯卡和迪克莱门特（Prochaska and Diclemente）提出的吗？我是不是记错了？我不知道，我想有很多，库伯勒-罗斯（Kübler-Ross）是一个经常被引用的模型，它与悲伤模型相关。我的意思是，围绕它的证据还有待商榷，但我知道它经常被用在工作环境中来谈论变革。那是从人们经历变革和驾驭变革的角度出发的，但还有大量的变革框架，涉及在工作中实施变革的最优模型。说来有趣，我在第一部分的一个项目就是研究所有不同的变革模型，并真正得出结论，试图从中获得最好的部分并提出最有帮助的东西。所以有很多不同的变革理论。有些东西比什么沉思、前沉思、行动、维持等等要深入得多。我认为最有效的框架是那些真正认识到上下文环境的重要性、参与度的重要性以及获得买单（buy-in）和参与的重要性、沟通的重要性的框架。因为我这些年学到的一件事是，当变革做得糟糕时，其根本原因通常是沟通不畅。
I also do quite a lot of teaching coaching basics to leaders to enable organizations to have kind of leaders as coach type programs. So I do quite a lot in terms of very simplified coaching. And then I have some jobs where it's more kind of paid for roles. So I'm a non-exec director for Southern Co-op. So that's a regional cooperative. And I sit on that board. But I'm also the board ambassador for D&I. I chair the remuneration committee.
所以沟通是一切的核心。是的，我认为当你审视员工团队的运作方式时，这非常有趣。我们都在一些运作得很好的团队中工作过，而另一些则完全不行。这是否是职业心理学家可以介入并解决以帮助团队蓬勃发展的事情呢？是的，绝对是。再次强调，取决于你选择走的路径，因为正如我所说，这非常有趣。我有一些 100% 从事选拔与评估的朋友，这就是他们的工作，他们做心理测验（psychometrics），关于招聘、选拔、评估，为职位寻找最合适的人选，这本身就非常专业。然后我有其他同行，他们的工作基本上是变革，无论是变革管理、协助变革、驾驭变革还是所有变革类型的事情。我还有其他同事做更多关于福祉、福祉倡议、福祉干预的事情。所以这取决于你决定走哪条路径。因为我比较喜欢，正如你可能意识到的那样，涉猎广泛，我更喜欢当有人来告诉我挑战是什么时，我会想：“我是合适的人选吗？我对此有所了解吗？我理解它吗？我能弄清底细吗？”然后我会觉得：“是的，这听起来像是我可以参与的事情。”所以，是的，但是有几种，
So some of the strengths from what I do overlays there and then as I mentioned I teach at Birkbeck on the master's program oh a little bit of variety is definitely the spice of life isn't it yes yes it is so yeah and you mentioned that you you really like change and for many of our listeners um or watchers um they might be thinking about the kind of stages of change model which is that is that prochaska and declemente have i imagined that i don't know i think there's quite a few i mean kubler ross is one that's cited often which is the one that's associated to the grief model i mean there's it's there's questionable evidence around it but I know it's one that okay often gets used in a work context to talk about change there's that's from a kind of
我不知道我有没有回答好这个问题，我是不是有点跑题了？没有，完全没问题。所以它听起来，我不知道，它让我想起了一点法医心理学，你必须对自己负责，把所有事情做好，并不断希望在正确的时间通过流程。是不是有一条你开始攻读博士学位的路径，三年后如果你达到了所有的标准，你就会被毕业，还是说它比这更加零碎？我认为特别针对伯克贝克学院的专业博士学位，有趣的是，其中的大多数人都有相当多的工作经验，所以我们已经在工作中，或者像我一样处于第二职业生涯。所以因为第一部分的性质，你正在做与工作相关的项目，你必须能够接触到那些工作。正如我所说，我的一些同行是受雇的，有些人……我想我在举一些个人的例子，但有人在选拔和评估方面工作，这几乎就是他们的工作。另一个人主要在 NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）做福祉倡议。所以这取决于上下文环境。但这种想法是，是的，它与你运作的上下文环境联系得更紧密，无论你是一名独立实践者还是受雇。而且因为这是一个相当漫长的旅程，显然我也有一些换了公司的同行。他们在做不同的事情，因为你是边工作边完成它的，所以每个人的路径本质上都会不同。
people experiencing change and navigating change but then there's a whole ton of change frameworks in terms of the the most optimal model of implementing a change at work. And funnily enough, one of my projects on my part one was looking at all the different change models and actually coming, trying to get the best out of and come up with something that was the most helpful. So there's lots of different theories of change. So there's stuff that's a little bit more in-depth than the, what is it, contemplation, pre-contemplation, action, you know, maintenance, all of that. And I think the most effective kind of frameworks are those that actually recognise, going back to the context and the importance of participation and the importance of kind of getting buy-in and involvement, those kind of communication. Because one thing I've kind of learned over the years is that when change is done badly, normally at the root cause is the communication is poor.
原来如此，谢谢。如果个人的情况合适，并且以前没有获得过太多资助，他们可以申请学生贷款之类的东西来帮助支付学费吗？不，我有能力自筹资金，而且因为我在学习期间一直在工作，我显然是一边工作一边赚钱的。它被归类为兼职，所以我当时在做这个，而且在某些时候几乎是全职工作。那么你最小的孩子现在多大了？从你第一次觉得“我不确定这是否行得通”开始，过去多少年了？是的，嗯，她实际上刚满 13 岁。所以她是个青少年了。
And so the communication is kind of at the heart of everything yeah I think it's really interesting when you look at kind of the way that staff teams function so you know we'll have all worked in some that work really well and others that just they just don't um is that kind of something that occupational psychologists could get in there and sort out to help help teams to thrive yeah absolutely and again depending on the pathway you sort of choose to go down because I said it's it is quite interesting I've got friends who 100% work in selection and assessment that's what they do they do psychometrics they you know it's about recruitment selection assessment finding the best people for roles and that in itself is is very specialized and then you've got i've got other peers who work
她大约是，是的，当我离开企业职位时她大约四岁。所以在过去的五年半里，我一直是一名学生，同时还在工作。所以是的，我现在是一个十几岁孩子的妈妈了，这有点吓人。太棒了，我处于即将进入青少年期的阶段，我有一个十岁半的孩子，这完全是另一回事。但天哪，那种你几乎处于悬崖边缘的感觉——“哦，我想我要走了，我想我要走了，我想我要走了，是的，我要跳下去，我要辞掉这份企业生活，我要做一些不同的事情”——这既令人兴奋又令人恐惧。是的，虽然我确实记得当时，正如我所暗示的那样，我绝对是在走向精疲力竭（burnout）的道路上，那就是我当时要去的地方。我工作过度，正如我所说，担任大角色，负有欧洲责任，领导庞大团队，并在三个不同的时区工作。因此，由于倾向于对太多事情说“好”，现在我知道那是通往精疲力竭的道路。所以实际上，当我从传送带上下来时，真是一种解脱，因为我认为如果我不这样做，我很清楚自己会走向何方。所以这非常需要，我记得当时有这样一种感觉，感觉重担被卸下了，能够突然变得有创意，因为我已经走出了那种让我感觉很不好的“忙碌仓鼠轮”。
fundamentally you know in change whether that's change management helping through change navigating change all the change type stuff i've got other colleagues who do stuff that's more around well-being well-being initiatives well-being interventions um so there's it kind of depends which kind of pathway you decide to go down um i've kind of because i kind of like as as you probably realize have my fingers in lots of pies i kind of like you know i'm more interested in someone comes and says what the challenge is and i kind of go am i the right person have i have i got some knowledge in this do i understand it kind I get to the bottom of it and then I'll be like yeah that sounds like something I could get involved in so um so yes but there are sort of
是的，我认为当我们做出决定并采取行动时，它在生理上以及我们的心理负担方面能产生多大的差异，这真是太惊人了。我记得当我试图决定是否停止为 NHS 工作时，心理负担非常沉重。任何时候我有空闲的几分钟，我都会试图权衡它。就像，我应该留下吗？我应该走吗？字面意思上，每次我去烧水壶时，我发现自己都在想这件事。这真的很难，一旦我做出了决定，我确实感到非常解放、自由和兴奋。倒不是说 NHS 不是一个工作的好地方，而是对我来说，我已经做出了决定，你知道，这真的赋予了我力量。是的，绝对的。所以听起来，掌控局面是减少心理学领域精疲力竭的关键秘诀之一，但这可能不是唯一的秘诀。你还有其他关于如何预防这种情况的想法吗？是的，我，我很感激你提到这可能是个问题，因为我真的对此进行了反思。因为我认为正是这种几乎走向那条道路的感觉，我认为这是原因之一，我对组织心理学的这种兴趣，知道工作强化是一个真实的事情，知道实际上我可以通过带入我的一些经验以及新获得的知识来对工作场所产生影响，以帮助教育人们，并帮助人们对他们对待工作的方式有不同的思考。如前所述，我天生就是一个倾向于做太多事情、对太多事情说“好”的人。如果有什么事情听起来真的很令人兴奋，我就会想：“哦，是的，哦，是的，我可以做到。”要认识到实际上我需要更好地设定界限，这真是一个非常大的挑战和经验。我想这可能是最大的一点，我在企业生涯中绝对是没有界限感地运作的。有人在晚上发给我电子邮件，我坐在那儿，手机就在那儿，所以我不妨回复，为什么不呢？所以这种没有任何思考的想法——第一，我在做什么，我为什么要在一个晚上 10 点回复电子邮件？第二，作为那种，我在传达什么信息？哦，我认为这没关系。所以我想，关于我们在什么时候沟通和不沟通要设定界限的这种想法——许多人说“哦，但那是适合我的时间”，就像“那太好了，但实际上你传递的是什么信息”一样。所以我认为围绕我们在何时应该工作、何时不应该工作以及沟通设定界限的整个事情，数字断开连接，围绕着“对我的家人来说，这不是把手机粘在身上等待下一条消息的时间”设定更多界限。所以围绕这一点有很多内容，而且它确实有帮助。我不知道你作为父母是否有同感。当你有了需要抚养的人时，它确实有帮助，因为你会说：“不，我想成为一个真正的好妈妈。所以我将在这个时候把它关掉。”
definitely I don't know if I've answered that very well have I kind of felt like I've digressed a bit no absolutely fine so it sounds it sounds kind of I don't know like it reminds me a little bit of forensic where you kind of have to hold yourself accountable get everything done and keep hoping to move through the process at the right time um is there like a a pathway that you kind of start on the doctor and then three years later you are spat out if you've kind of met all the thresholds or is it a little bit more piecemeal than that? I think the interesting thing with specifically with this with the professional doctorate at Birkbeck you know the most people on it have had quite a bit of work experience so we're already you know in work um or have you
我认为拥有我的女儿使我能够设定更多界限，而这以前我是做不到的。所以我想这绝对有这方面的因素。我的首要秘诀——我才刚刚开始实施它，但当我最近这样做时，我感到相当有赋能感。正如我所说，当人们带着机会来找我时，我总是想：“哦，听起来真的很兴奋，我想我会真的很享受那个，是的。”然后看看我的日程表，说：“哦，天哪，我为什么要那样说？”所以我有了一个新招，就是我说：“我能晚点回复你吗？”或者“让我想想那个。”我有幸拥有一个有很好界限感的丈夫，我可以向他反馈。我会对他说，他会说：“当然，你为什么要对那个说好？你有一大堆事情要做。”所以我有一个理性的声音在对我喊叫，但也只是有时间去说：“好的，我知道这真的很兴奋，听起来真的很棒。但你还有其他什么事情要做？如果你那样做会有什么影响？”然后再回去说：“非常感谢你的邀请，但根据我目前手头上的其他事情，我做不到，”或者说：“或者说，‘好的，我会做，但它有这些附带条件。’”所以这相当新，相当……我觉得我是第一批经历这种事情的人之一，因为你对我就这样做过。你当时说：“让我看看，让我看看，也许研究一下，让我想想，然后回复你。”你知道，我真的很感激。你知道，我希望你觉得你是选择这样做，你觉得这是一件值得做的事情，但完全可以要求更多信息，要求一些时间来思考，去查看日程表，计划你可能什么时候能做那件事。我认为这非常普遍，尤其是在有抱负的心理学家中，你想要积极热忱，你想要把事情做好，你想要说“好、好、好、好、好”。但如果这意味着你超负荷了，日程表里有太多事情，你无法兼顾这一切，你知道，那将是通往精疲力竭的道路。学会说“不”，或者如果你不一定想对你的导师说“不”，可以说：“你能帮我看一下日程表，想想从优先级的角度来看最紧迫的事情是什么，这样我们就能确保所有事情都能以满足你的需求和我的需求的方式完成吗？”是的，我真的认为……一般来说，当我因为我与领导者做很多工作，我真的注意到这种说“好的”的倾向、不质疑截止日期的倾向、默认一切都是紧急的（当它不是时）的倾向、默认一切都是重要的（当它有时不是时）的倾向。而这种说“还不行”或“不”或“我可以想想吗”的想法，确实赋予了力量。最初人们可能会想：“如果我这么说，别人会怎么看我？”我认为这是害怕受到社会评判的观念，害怕人们会怎么想——他们会认为我应付得不好吗？他们会认为我不擅长确定优先级吗？老实说，根据我的经验，你会发现，当你真正表现出“我在掌控之中，我正在告诉你我的能力是多少”时，你实际上会获得更多的赞誉和尊重。所以我想这是组织中的许多员工和领导者可以学习的东西。绝对非常重要，谢谢你与我们分享这一点。你知道，人们在他们生活的所有阶段、职业的所有阶段都在收听或观看这个播客。如果他们听到这个，心想：“哦，这听起来像是我的风格”，为了推动他们的职业生涯向前发展，他们应该做的最好的事情是什么？我认为首先也是最重要的，这显然取决于你的年龄和阶段，但如果你还没有组织心理学硕士学位，这真的是第一步。我想对于那些有心理学背景的人来说，这是一条更轻松的切入路径，但即使没有心理学本科学位，你也可以攻读硕士学位的职业或组织心理学。所以对于那些没有本科学位的有抱负的心理学家来说，这是个好消息，因为我也没有。这可能意味着这是一个稍微陡峭的学习曲线，但没关系。
know like me was on a you know second career um so it's and because of the nature of the part one that you are doing work-related projects you have to have access to the those work um as i said some some of my peers were employed some you know within kind of think what i'm just citing some of the individuals but you know someone who they worked for in selection assessment that's pretty much what they did someone else who is mainly doing well-being initiatives in nhs um so it kind of it it depends on on on. But that idea that, yeah, it's more linked to their context in which you which you're operating, whether you're or an independent practitioner or whether you're employed. And then because it's quite a long journey, I've got obviously peers as well who've who've moved companies. They're doing different things because you're kind of doing it alongside working it's it kind of yes everyone's path is going to be different essentially.
你知道的，就像我一样，我也是在经历第二次职业生涯，所以因为第一部分项目的性质，你必须要做与工作相关的项目，你必须能够接触到那些工作。就像我说的，我的一些同伴有工作，有的人在某些领域工作——我只是举几个人的例子——比如有人从事选拔评估工作，基本上就是他们所做的事情；还有的人主要在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）做健康倡议项目。所以这在很大程度上取决于具体情况。但这种想法是，它更多地与你所处的环境相关，无论你是独立从业者还是受雇于人。而且因为这是一个相当漫长的过程，我显然也有一些换了公司的同行。他们在做不同的事情，因为你是一边工作一边完成这个过程，所以基本上每个人的道路都是不同的。
I see thank you and obviously if the circumstances for the person are right and they've not had too much funding before can they apply for kind of student loan things to kind of help with their fees and things no I was in a position to be able to sell fund and because I was working for the duration I was obviously earning whilst doing so it is classed as a part-time so I was doing this and pretty much working at times full time as well. So and how old is your youngest child now? How many years has it taken from when you first thought, I'm not sure this is working? Yeah, well, she's just turned 13, actually. So she's a teenager.
我明白了，谢谢。显然，如果一个人的情况合适，以前没有获得过太多资助，他们可以申请那种学生贷款来帮助支付学费吗？不，我当时的情况能够自给自足，而且因为我在整个过程中一直在工作，所以我一边做一边赚钱。这被归类为兼职，所以我一边做这个，有时甚至全职工作。那么，你最小的孩子现在多大了？从你第一次觉得“我不确定这是否行得通”开始，已经过去多少年了？是的，她其实刚满13岁。所以她是个青少年了。
She was about, yeah, she was she was four when I left my corporate role and so for the last five and a half years I've been you know a student and working at the same time so yes I'm now a mum of a teenager which is a bit scary amazing I'm I'm sort of hovering at the preteen I've got a ten and a half year old it's a whole different ball game but oh my gosh that sense of you almost on this precipice of like oh I think I'm going I think I'm going I think I'm going yep I'm gonna jump off I'm quitting this corporate life and I'm gonna do something different which is exhilarating but also terrifying yeah although I do remember at the time I mean as I kind of alluded to I was absolutely going down a pathway to burnout that's where I was headed um I was overworking I was
她大概……对的，我离开公司职位时她大约四岁。所以在过去的五年半里，我一直是一边当学生一边工作。所以是的，我现在是一个十几岁孩子的妈妈了，这有点吓人，但也很神奇。我正处于青春期前的阶段，我有一个十岁半的孩子，这完全是另一码事。但是哦天哪，那种你几乎处于悬崖边缘的感觉，比如“哦，我想我要去，我想我要去，我想我要去，是的，我要跳下去了，我要辞掉这个企业生活，我要去做点不一样的事”，这既让人兴奋又让人感到恐惧。是的，虽然我确实记得当时，正如我刚才暗示的那样，我绝对是在走向精疲力竭的道路，那是我当时正要前往的方向。我过度工作，我
working as said big role uh European responsibility large team and um working in three different different time zones so um and with a propensity to say yes to too much uh now that i know that uh that was a pathway i was heading down so actually when i you know got off the conveyor belt it was such a relief because i think i knew where i was headed um had I not so um it was yeah it was a much needed I remember at the time having this kind of feeling just yeah my weight lifted and been able to kind of suddenly be creative because I'd come out of this kind of hamster wheel of busyness which was not serving me well yeah I think it's amazing what difference it can make to us physically and in terms of our mental load as well when we make a decision and we take action
正如我所说，我担任着大角色，承担着欧洲区的责任，领导着庞大的团队，而且在三个不同的时区工作。因此，我倾向于对太多事情说“好”。现在我知道那是一条通往精疲力竭的路。所以实际上，当我摆脱那个传送带时，真是一种巨大的解脱，因为我想我知道自己要去哪里，如果我没有这么做的话……所以，这是一个非常需要的……我记得当时有这种感觉，就像心里的石头落地了，能够突然变得有创意，因为我已经走出了这种无休止的忙碌仓鼠轮，这对我的健康毫无益处。是的，我认为当我们做出决定并采取行动时，这对我们的身体和精神负担会产生多么大的改变
and it seems like we're doing like a purposeful purposeful goal then I remember when I was trying to decide whether or not to stop working for the NHS and the mental load was so heavy. Anytime I had a spare couple of minutes, I'd be trying to weigh it up. Like, should I stay? Should I go? Like literally every time I went to boil the kettle, that's what I found myself thinking about. And it's just really hard and once I'd made that decision I did just feel so liberated and free and excited not because the NHS is a bad place to work for but for me I'd made my decision and you know they're really empowering yeah yeah absolutely so it sounds like taking control is one of your key tips for reducing burnouts in the psychology
这似乎就像我们在朝着一个有目的的目标前进。我记得当我试图决定是否停止为NHS工作时，精神负担太重了。任何时候只要有空闲的几分钟，我都在权衡。比如：我应该留下吗？我应该离开吗？字面意思上，每次我去烧水壶烧水时，我都发现自己在想这个。这真的很难。一旦我做出了那个决定，我真的感到非常解放、自由和兴奋。倒不是说NHS是一个不好的工作地方，而是对我而言，我已经做出了决定，你知道的，这真的很赋能。是的，绝对的。所以听起来，夺回控制权是你在心理学领域减少精疲力竭的关键秘诀之一
sphere but it might not be your only one have you got any other kind of ideas for how how that can be prevented yes I've and I I was appreciated you mentioning that this might be a question because I really did reflect on this because I think it was that you know this this almost as they're going heading down that pathway um that was I think one of the reasons you know this I this interest in organizational psychology knowing that this is you know work intensification is a real thing and knowing that actually I can make a difference to workplaces by bringing some of my experience and then newly acquired knowledge to help kind of educate and help people kind of think differently about how they approach work. As I said, I am I am naturally someone who has a propensity to do too much, to say yes to too many things. If something sounds really exciting, I'm like, oh, yeah, oh, yeah, I could do that. And it's been a real, real kind of challenge and experience, you know,
但这可能不是唯一的秘诀。你还有其他关于如何预防这种情况的想法吗？是的，我很感激你提到这可能是一个问题，因为我确实对此进行了反思。因为我认为正是这种几乎要走向那条道路的感觉……我认为这也是我对组织心理学产生兴趣的原因之一，我知道工作集约化是一个真实存在的问题。我知道实际上我可以通过将我的一些经验和新获得的知识带到工作中来做出改变，帮助教育人们并帮助他们以不同的方式看待工作方式。就像我说的，我天生就是一个倾向于做太多事情、对太多事情说“好”的人。如果某事听起来真的很令人兴奋，我就会说：“哦，是的，哦，是的，我可以做那个。”这确实是一个真正的挑战和经验，你知道的，
learning experience to try and recognize that actually I need to be better at being more boundaried. And I think that's probably the biggest thing is that i i absolutely during my corporate career did not operate with boundaries um you know someone sends me an email in an evening and i'm sitting my phone's there so i might as well reply why not and so that idea of not having any kind of thought around well one what am i doing why am I replying to an email at 10 o'clock at night and two what what message is that sending out as a as that well I think that this is okay so I think that idea of being boundaried around um when we communicate and lots of people say oh that but that's the time that suits me it's like that's great but actually what message are you
这是一个学习的过程，试图认识到实际上我需要更好地设定界限。我认为这可能是最重要的事情，那就是我在企业职业生涯中绝对没有设定边界。有人在晚上给我发电子邮件，我坐在那儿，手机就在旁边，所以我不妨回复，为什么不呢？所以这种没有任何想法的概念——第一，我在做什么？为什么我要在晚上10点回复电子邮件？第二，作为那种榜样，我传达了什么信息？我认为这没问题。所以我觉得，在我们的沟通方式上设定界限的想法……很多人说：“哦，但那是适合我的时间。”就像是：“那很好，但实际上你传达的是什么信息？”
sending out so I think that whole thing around being boundaried around when we should and shouldn't be working and communicating um the sort of digital switch off being more boundaried around going with my family this is not time to have my phone attached to my you know waiting for the next message so I think there's lots around that kind of, and it does actually help. I don't know if you find the same as being a parent. It does kind of help when you've got a dependence because you kind of say, actually, no, I want to be a really good mom. So I am going to switch this off at this time.
所以我认为围绕我们何时应该和不应该工作以及沟通的整个问题，包括数字断联，以及在陪伴家人时设定更多的边界——这不是让手机黏在我身上等待下一条消息的时间。所以有很多关于这方面的做法，而且确实很有帮助。我不知道你作为父母是否有同感。当你有了需要照顾的人时，这确实有帮助，因为你会说：“不，实际上我想做一个非常好的妈妈。所以我会在这个时候把它关掉。”
I think having my daughter has enabled me to be a bit more um a bit more boundaried that I wasn't before so I think there's definitely something around that um my top tip I've only just started implementing it but I felt I felt quite empowered when I did it recently so as I said when people come to me with opportunities I always think oh that sounds really exciting I think I'd really enjoy that yes and then kind of look at my diary and go oh my gosh why did I say that um so I've got a new thing which is I said can can I get back to you on that or let me think about that and I benefit from having a husband who's well-boundaried who I then have the kind of
我认为拥有我的女儿让我能够比以前更有边界感。所以我觉得这方面绝对有一些东西。我的顶级秘诀——我才刚开始实施它，但当我最近这样做时，我感到相当有赋能感。就像我说的，当人们带着机会来找我时，我总是想：“哦，听起来真的很令人兴奋，我想我会真的很喜欢那个，好的。”然后看一眼我的日历，心里想：“哦天哪，我为什么要说那个？”所以我有一个新方法，那就是我说：“我能晚点回复你吗？”或者“让我想一想。”我很幸运有一个很有边界感的丈夫，我然后可以向他
come back to you on it. I'll say to him, he's like, of course, why are you saying yes to that? You've got tons of things on. So I have a kind of voice of reason shouting at me, but also just having that time to then go, right. I know this is really exciting. This sounds really great. But what else have you got going on? What is going to be the impact if you do that and then going back and then saying actually thank you so much for the offer but based on what else I've got on right now I can't I can't do it or saying or saying actually yeah I'm gonna do it but it comes with these caveats so that is quite new it's quite well I feel like I am one of the first people to have
回复。我会对他说，而他会说：“当然，你为什么对那个说好？你手头有一堆事情要做。”所以我有一个清醒的声音在对我大喊大叫，但也有时间去想：“好的，我知道这真的很兴奋，听起来很棒，但你手头还有什么？如果你做了这个，会产生什么影响？”然后再回去说：“非常感谢您的邀请，但基于我目前手头上其他的事情，我做不了。”或者说：“好吧，我要做，但它有这些前提条件。”所以这挺新的。我觉得我似乎是第一批
experienced that because you did that to me you were like let me have a look let me have a look maybe research let me think about it and come back to you and you know I really I really appreciated that you know I want you to feel like you're choosing to do this and that you feel like it's a worthwhile thing to do but it's it's absolutely okay to ask for more information to ask for some time to think to kind of look at the diary to plan when you might be able to do that. And I think it's really common, especially in aspiring psychologists, you want to be keen, you want to get things done, you want to say yes, yes, yes, yes, yes. But then if it means that you are over full, you've got too much in your diary, you can't do
经历过这种感受的人之一，因为你就是这样对我的。你说过：“让我看一看，让我看一看，也许研究一下，让我想想再回复你。”你知道的，我真的很感激。你知道，我希望你觉得你是自愿选择做这件事的，你觉得这是一件值得做的事情。但是，要求获得更多信息、要求一些时间思考、查看日历、计划你什么时候可以做这件事，这绝对是没有问题的。我认为这非常普遍，尤其是在有抱负的心理学家中，你想要表现得积极，你想要完成事情，你想要说：“好，好，好，好，好。”但如果这意味着你超负荷了，日历上排满了事情，你就无法完成
it all, you know, and that will be a path to burnout. learning to say no or you know if you don't necessarily want to say no to your supervisor to say could you help me look at my diary to think about the things that are most pressing in terms of priority so that we can make sure that everything gets done in a way that that meets your needs and mine yeah I think you know and generally I when I because I do a lot of work with leaders and I'm really picking up this kind of propensity to say yes, propensity to not question deadlines, to propensity to assume everything's urgent when it's not, propensity to assume everything's important when it's sometimes not. And this idea of kind of saying not yet or no, or can I think about it?
所有这些，你知道的，那将会是一条通往精疲力竭的路。学会说“不”，或者如果你不一定想对你的主管说“不”，可以说：“你能帮我看看我的日历，想想在优先级方面最紧迫的事情是什么，这样我们就能确保所有事情都以满足你我需求的方式完成吗？”是的，我确实认为，通常当我——因为我和许多领导者合作，我真的感受到了这种倾向，即倾向于说“好”，倾向于不去质疑截止日期，倾向于在一切并非紧急时假设其紧急，倾向于在有时并非重要时假设其重要。这种说“还没到时候”或“不”，或者“我能考虑一下吗”的想法，
It is empowering. And I think initially people kind of think not yet or no or can I think about it it is empowering and I think initially people kind of think oh what what might others think of me if I say that and I think this is it's this kind of notion of fearing social judgment of you know what people are going to think are they going to think I'm not coping very well they're going to think I'm not very good at prioritizing honestly from my experience I find you get actually more kudos and respect when you are actually demonstrating I'm I'm I'm in control and I'm telling you what my capacity is so I think it is something that you know a lot of employees and leaders in organizations can can kind of learn from absolutely so important thanks for sharing that with us so you know people are listening to this podcast or watching it at all
是赋予人力量的。我认为最初人们可能会想：“如果我这么说，别人会怎么看我？”我认为这就是这种对社交评判的恐惧的概念，担心人们会怎么想，他们会觉得我应付不来吗？他们会觉得我不擅长优先排序吗？老实说，根据我的经验，你会发现当你真正展现出“我在掌控之中，我在告诉你我的能力极限”时，你实际上会获得更多的声誉和尊重。所以我想这是组织中的许多员工和领导者可以学习的东西。绝对如此，非常重要，谢谢你与我们分享这些。所以你知道，人们在他们生活的各个阶段、职业生涯的各个阶段都在收听或观看这个播客，
stages of their life all stages of their career if they're like listening to this thinking oh that sounds like a bit of me um what's the best thing that they should do in terms of trying to move their career forward so I think first and foremost if it depends depends obviously on your kind of age and stage but if um if you've not already got a master's in organizational psychology that is really or occupational psychology that is really the the first step um i guess for those who have a psychology background that's that's an easier route in but you can get on an msc occupational organizational psychology without having an undergraduate degree in psychology so that's good news if there's aspiring psychologists who haven't got the undergrad because I didn't. It might mean it's a slightly steeper learning curve, but that's OK.
如果他们听了这些，心里想“哦，这听起来有点像我的情况”，那么在试图推动他们的职业生涯向前发展方面，他们应该做的最好的事情是什么？所以我认为首先也是最重要的，这显然取决于你的年龄和阶段，但如果你还没有获得组织心理学硕士学位，那真的，或者说职业心理学，那真的是第一步。我想对于那些有心理学背景的人来说，这是一条更容易切入的途径，但即使没有心理学本科学位，你也可以攻读职业组织心理学理学硕士（MSc）。所以对于那些没有本科学位的有抱负的心理学家来说，这是好消息，因为我当时就没有。这可能意味着学习曲线会稍微陡峭一点，但没关系。
So the kind of the MSC is kind of the pathway in because that then gives you, you know, organizational psychologist kind of credentials. And then as to kind of how you want to take that you know i know lots of my students who have done their masters and are you know that's that's where they that's where they want to kind of end the education but are doing you know really thriving in various different jobs um as i said it's it's so interesting because you know you can have someone who's working for a management consultancy doing change stuff you've got someone over here is working for a recruitment in psychometrics and selection you've got someone over here who's working for a you know a consultancy who do well-being initiatives it's so varied I think that's the part and if you're interested in work
所以职业心理学硕士（MSC）某种程度上算是一个切入点，因为它能为你提供组织心理学相关的资质认证。至于你未来想往哪个方向发展，我知道很多学生读完硕士后，就觉得这就是他们教育的终点，但他们在各种不同的工作岗位上也做得风生水起。正如我所说，这真的很有趣，因为你可以看到有人在管理咨询公司从事变革管理工作，有人在搞招聘、心理测量和人才选拔，还有人在做福祉相关的咨询项目。领域真的是太广泛了，我觉得如果你对工作世界感兴趣的话...
if you're interested in the world of work you can kind of find your passion and interest in many different kind of domains and they require very different skills. So I think that's why it's quite a broad, it's quite a broad kind of domain. Perfect. Thank you so much for sharing your time and your knowledge and expertise with us today. Where should people come and follow you? Is LinkedIn the best place to contact you or reach out or just be inspired by your wonderful work and posts? Oh, yes. Probably LinkedIn's a good place. I try to try to share content on there. I do a quick plug. I'm actually writing a book now. So but it's quite early doors but hopefully
如果你对工作世界感兴趣，你可以在许多不同的领域中找到自己的热情和兴趣，而这些领域所需的技能也大不相同。所以我觉得这是一个非常广阔、非常多元的领域。太棒了，非常感谢你今天抽出时间与我们分享你的知识和专业专长。大家应该去哪里关注你呢？领英（LinkedIn）是联系你、与你取得联系或者从你精彩的工作和动态中获得灵感的最隹平台吗？哦，是的，领英可能是一个好地方。我尽量在上面分享一些内容。我顺便打个小广告，其实我正在写一本书。不过目前还处于早期阶段，希望...
this time next year my book will soon be published so my research interest in proactive behavior work has led to an opportunity to write in that area so a business I'm working on a business book that's around how leaders can create the right conditions for proactive behavior work to flourish. So that's what I'm going to be writing over the coming weeks and months. My LinkedIn posts are going to be sharing more around my own research in proactive behavior. So if you're interested in proactive behavior motivation, then I'll be feeding more insights over the coming weeks and months mainly on LinkedIn. So you are Jo Gray on LinkedIn, Doctor in Occupational Psychology it says there and I will look forward to learning more about you and your book and if you wanted to come back on and talk to us about that at any stage when the time is right please let us know but yeah I
明年这个时候我的书就能出版了。我在工作中的前瞻性行为方面的研究兴趣让我获得了在该领域写作的机会。所以我在写一本商业书，主要探讨领导者如何为员工的前瞻性行为蓬勃发展创造正确的条件。这就是我接下来几周和几个月要写的内容。我的领英动态也会更多地分享我关于前瞻性行为的研究。所以如果你对前瞻性行为动机感兴趣，我会在接下来的几周和几个月里在领英上分享更多见解。所以在领英上你叫乔·格雷（Jo Gray），上面写着你是职业心理学博士。我很期待更多地了解你和你的书。如果在合适的时候你想回来跟我们聊聊这个，请随时告诉我们。不过是的，我...
was thinking when you were saying you know people decide when they get to MSc that they're just going to stop and I was thinking often we think we're done and we're not like I think whenever I finish a book I think I'm down I'm never doing that again if you finish some education I'm never doing that again and you're like I might just do this thing it's funny that you've already got a thing yes I know do you know what I was I was mindful that because lots of people said that when you come to the end of a like a PhD or doctorate you kind of you're almost like that oh and that's it I've reached it and I ran a few marathons in the past and I have had post-marathon blues we were a bit like what now so actually the book was a really nice little next thing so that I didn't have that big
刚才在想，你提到很多人读完硕士后就决定到此为止了，我当时就在想，通常我们以为自己完成了，其实并没有。就像我觉得每次写完一本书，我都觉得搞定了，再也不干了；或者完成某些学业后，觉得再也不读书了。但你又会想：‘我或许可以再搞这么一下。’挺有意思的，你竟然已经给自己安排了下一个任务。哈哈，我知道，你知道吗，我是因为考虑到很多人说过，当你读完博士学位时，你会有那种感觉——‘哦，就这样了，我终于到了终点。’我过去跑过几次马拉松，也有过‘马拉松后抑郁’，当时就会觉得‘接下来该干嘛呢’。所以实际上，写这本书是一个非常棒的后续安排，这样我就不会经历那种严重的...
dip of what next so I proactively set that up well I hope that it goes really well for you and I hope that your amendments get signed off with no problem and you enjoy your career as an occupational psychologist thank you thanks much. And thanks to everyone for listening. I really appreciate the opportunity. Thank you. Oh, you're so welcome. Thank you. Thank you so much for listening. What a lovely conversation it was with Jo. Please do go and follow her on LinkedIn. She is Jo Gray over there. There will be details in the show notes. Whilst you're at it, come and connect with me as well. I am Dr. Marianne Trent on all of my socials. And you can also come and join the
失落感和‘接下来干嘛’的迷茫了。所以我提前把这件事安排好了。嗯，我希望你的新书一切顺利，希望你的修改意见能顺利通过，也希望你作为一名职业心理学家的职业生涯能够顺风顺水。非常感谢。同时也感谢所有收听节目的听众，非常感谢大家的支持。不客气，谢谢你们。非常感谢大家的收听。这是一次多么愉快的对话啊，嘉宾是乔（Jo）。请大家一定要去领她在领英上关注她，她在那里的名字是乔·格雷（Jo Gray）。节目简介里会有详细信息。顺便说一句，也来跟我连线吧！在所有的社交媒体上我都是玛丽安·特ント博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）。你也可以加入...
Aspiring Psychologist Community free Facebook group. And you can also, if you would like to, consider joining the Aspiring Psychologist membership so that I can help you with your next rung on your ladder thank you so much for being part of my world I will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the aspiring psychologist podcast which will be along to you very soon take care Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent my name is Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner
“有志心理学家社区”（Aspiring Psychologist Community）免费脸书（Facebook）群组。如果你愿意的话，也可以考虑加入“有志心理学家会员”（Aspiring Psychologist membership），这样我就可以在你的职业阶梯上助你一臂之力。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我期待在下一期的“有志心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）中与大家见面，新节目很快就会上线，保重！那么，让这首歌成为你的指引，有这个播客陪在你身边，你将在通往合格的道路上前进。这就是《有志心理学家播客》，我是玛丽安·特ント博士，我的名字叫贾娜（Jana），是一名心理健康实习从业人员。
I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我读了《临床心理学家集体之书》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective book），觉得里面关于各种不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。通往这个职业的途径居然有这么多，而且没有哪一种是成为心理学家的唯一完美方式，这让我感到非常惊叹。这给了我极大的信心，让我觉得我并没有走错路，从而减轻了我的心理压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些忐忑不安，我绝对推荐你读读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会把书放下了。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。